Adriene: Hi I'm Adriene Hill, welcome back
to Crash Course Economics. As you may remember
from our first video, economics can be divided
into two parts: microeconomics and macroeconomics.
Since macroeconomics is the one that's most
often in the news, that's where we're gonna
start. We'll get to microeconomics, which
is also super important in future episodes,
but what is macroeconomics again?
Mr. Clifford: (monotone) It's the study of
economic aggregates revealed through national
income accounting, which is then-
Adriene: Okay okay, when you explain it like
that it sounds boring but it is not boring!
Macro is about booms and busts, will you get a job
when you graduate, should the government cut taxes?
Mr. Clifford: In theory, lowering marginal
tax rates would actually increase-
Adriene: No no no! Remember, the goal of learning
economics is to become a better decision maker,
and part of that is learning how the whole economy
works. So let's learn about the whole economy.
[Theme Music]
So, macroeconomics is the study of the entire
economy. Macroeconomists study the big stuff,
like economic output, unemployment, inflation,
interest rates, and government policies.
Now when it comes to fields of study, macroeconomics
is a relatively new subject. It wasn't until
the Great Depression in the 1930's that economists
fully appreciated the need for a systematic way to
measure the overall economy, and that we might need
theories to guide policies and fix potential problems.
A hundred years ago there was no comprehensive
data on economic activity, so there was no
macroeconomics. Today, economic data is plentiful,
but that doesn't mean that economists agree
about where the economy is, where it's going,
or what should be done to help. Macroeconomists
make predictions based on data, theoretical models and
historical trends, but in the end they're just predictions.
If you ask three economists the same question,
you're likely to get three different answers,
but how, you ask, can the dismal "science"
be so subjective? Well, economics is not a
traditional science because it is nearly impossible
to control all the different variables. Like
all the social sciences, economics is studying people,
and it turns out that sometimes people are unpredictable.
Stan Muller: I challenge all of you to a tournament
of champions in Flappy Bird!
Adriene: Who saw that coming?
That doesn't mean that economics is all guesswork.
For example, right now in early 2015, the
economy of Greece is, well it's not, it's
not good. But how can we tell, and is it gonna
get better? Is it gonna get worse? What should
be done about it?
These are all questions that macroeconomists
try to answer, but for this video, we're gonna
focus on the question "How can we tell?"
Mr. Clifford: Well in general, policy makers
have three economic goals: they want to keep
the economy growing over time, they want to
limit unemployment, and they want to keep
prices stable. Now for the most part when
these three things happen, the citizens are
happy, politicians get reelected, and economists
get raises.
There are three specific measurements that
economists analyze to see if a country is
achieving each goal. They're the Gross Domestic
Product, unemployment rate, and the inflation rate.
The most important measure of an economy is
Gross Domestic Product or GDP. GDP is the
value of all final goods and services
produced within a country's border in a
specific period of time, usually a year.
Now there are some details worth mentioning.
GDP doesn't include every transaction that's
in the economy. For example, if you buy a
used domestic car, it doesn't count towards
GDP because nothing new was produced. Now
that same logic applies to buying financial
assets like stocks, or when one company buys
another company, for example when Google bought
YouTube. Those don't count towards GDP because
no new good or service was produced.
Also, GDP often doesn't include illegal activity,
since drug dealers don't usually report their
sales to the government, or non-traditional
economic activity like household production.
For example, if a plumber charges someone
$100 to fix their hot water heater, that counts
towards GDP, when he fixes his own water heater,
that doesn't count towards GDP.
Here's a list of countries organized by GDP.
Notice that GDP is measured in dollars, not
in the raw number of things produced. If we
analyzed just the raw number, then a country
that produced five million thumbtacks would
look like they're doing just as well as a
country that produced five million cars, but
there's also a problem with using the dollar
value of stuff produced: it's inflation.
If two countries produce the same amount of
cars, but one has higher prices, then that
country's going to have a higher nominal GDP,
or GDP not adjusted for inflation. To get
a more accurate idea of the health of the
economy, economists look at Real GDP, which
is GDP adjusted for inflation. Just what "adjusted
for inflation" means is really important,
but too big of a topic to discuss right now.
We'll get to it.
Adriene: So what does the Real GDP in Greece
tell us about its economy? In 2013, the Greek
Real GDP was around 242 billion dollars, but
that number doesn't really mean anything until
you compare it to previous years.
In 2012, it was 250 billion dollars, in 2011,
it was 288 billion, and in 2010 it was 300
billion. In fact, starting in 2008, Greece
has had six years of decreasing GDP, and the
data reveals that this recession is just as
deep and prolonged as the Great Depression
in the United States in the 1930's.
Now, I just used the term recession, which
a lot of people use incorrectly. A recession
is not just when the economy's bad, officially
it's when two successive quarters or six months
show a decrease in Real GDP. Even though the
economy in Greece is still struggling, it
climbed out of its recession in 2014, experiencing
a slight increase in GDP.
A depression, on the other hand, doesn't have
a technical definition, but it's a severe
recession, when the economy's really really
bad. It's worth noting though that GDP can
be a little problematic. I mean not all countries
measure GDP in the same way, and in recent
years some European Union countries have started
experimenting with counting underground markets,
like the sex trade and drug trade as part
of the total.
In fact, GDP isn't even that old an idea.
According to Robert Froyen, during the Great
Depression, economic decisions were made "on
the basis of such sketchy data as stock price
indices, freight car loadings, and incomplete
indices of industrial production. The fact
was that comprehensive measures of national
income and output did not exist at the time.
The depression, and with it the growing role
of government in the economy, emphasized the
need for such measures and led to the development
of a comprehensive set of national income accounts."
So GDP was invented to account for national
income, and it may not necessarily provide
a complete picture of a country's economy,
but for the moment it's what we've got.
So that's economic growth, or at least one
way to look at economic growth. now, for the
next big issue for macroeconomists: unemployment.
Anyway, the major goal of unemployment policy
is to limit unemployment, and that's measured
by - you guessed it - the unemployment rate.
In Greece, unemployment is over 25%.
Mr Clifford: The unemployment rate is calculated
by taking the number of people that are unemployed
and dividing by the number of people in the
labor force, times 100. Now this percentage
represents the number of people that are actively
looking for a job but just can't find one.
First, the labor force only includes people
that are of legal working age and working
or actively looking for work, so little kids
don't count and neither do people who aren't
able to work or who just choose not to work.
So what about someone who's been looking for
a job but just gives up? Well, they're no
longer part of the labor force, and they're
no longer considered unemployed. These are
called discouraged workers.
The unemployment rate also doesn't take into
account people that are underemployed. A worker
with a five hour a week part time job is considered
fully employed even if they're looking for a better
job. In both of these cases, the official  unemployment
rate underestimates the problems in the labor market.
A common misconception is that the goal is
to have 0% unemployment, but it turns out
there's types of unemployment that'll exist even
when the economy's going strong. Economists would
point out that there's three types of unemployment,
or three reasons why people would be unemployed.
First is frictional unemployment. This is
when people are temporarily unemployed or
between jobs. So if you quit your job and
look for a new one, or if you're just entering
the labor force, then you're frictionally
unemployed.
The second is called structural unemployment.
Workers are out of work because there's no
demand for that specific type of labor. This
would be like a VCR repair person, but it
also includes technological unemployment,
where workers are replaced by machines.
Now both frictional and structural unemployment
will always exist; the goal is not to have
0% unemployment. I mean, 0% is not even possible.
We're always going to have people between
jobs or people fired because machines do it
better.
So the goal is to have no cyclical unemployment.
This is unemployment due to a recession. It's
when people stop buying stuff, so businesses
lay off their workers and since workers have
lower incomes, they stop buying stuff which
means more people lose their jobs.
An economy is considered to be at full employment
when there's only frictional and structural
unemployment. This is called the natural rate
of unemployment. This natural rate differs
slightly between countries, in the United States
it's usually between 4 to 6 percent unemployment.
Now as you might expect the GDP growth rate
and the unemployment rate are inversely related.
That means that when GDP is rising, the unemployment
rate is falling, when GDP is falling, the unemployment rate is rising.
Adriene: And that's exactly what happened
in the United States during the Great Depression.
in the 1930's, droughts, bank failures, and
counterproductive policies caused GDP to fall,
and unemployment peaked at 25 percent.
Let's move on to the third economic goal:
stable prices. While I might like the idea
of the stuff I buy getting cheaper across
the board, falling prices are not really a
good thing. Average prices in Greece have
fallen about two percent recently, and during
the 1930's, the inflation rate in the US was
negative ten percent, but how can cheaper
stuff be bad for the economy?
Mr. Clifford: Well the goal is to keep prices
stable, mainly to avoid rapid inflation, or
rising prices, but we also want to avoid excessive
deflation which is falling prices. Inflation
is measured by tracking the prices of a set
amount of commonly purchased items, or what
economists call a market basket. The inflation rate is
the percent change in the price of that basket over time.
Too much inflation is bad because it decreases
the purchasing power of money; it means you
can buy less stuff with the same amount of
money, which has all sorts of negative effects
on the economy. Business costs increase as
workers demand higher wages and interest rates
increase, so it's harder to buy loans, so
people buy less cars and houses.
Deflation on the other hand, seems like it
would be a good thing but most economists
see falling prices as a bad thing. Falling
prices actually discourage people from spending
since they might expect prices to fall more
in the future. Less spending in the economy
means GDP is gonna decrease and unemployment's
gonna increase, and that just becomes a vicious
cycle. So severe recessions are often accompanied
by deflation because the demand for goods
and services falls, but when the economy starts
to improve again, we often see an increase in prices.
Adriene: Throughout history, economies have
expanded and contracted. It's called the business
cycle. Let's go to the Thought Bubble.
If we imagine the economy as a car, then GDP,
employment and inflation are the gauges. A
car can cruise along at 65 miles per hour
without overheating. Safe cruising speed is
like full employment; unemployment is low,
prices are stable and people are happy.
But if we drive that car too fast for too
long, it'll overheat, and in the economy,
significant spending increases GDP causing
an expansion. Unemployment falls and factories
start producing at full capacity to keep up
with demand. Since the amount of products
that can be produced is limited, people start
to outbid each other, resulting in inflation.
Eventually, production costs increase as workers
demand higher wages and the economy starts
to slow down. Businesses lay off a few workers,
those unemployed workers spend less causing
the businesses that produce the good that they
would otherwise be buying to lay off more workers.
This is a contraction, the economy is going
to slow. Eventually things stabilize, production
costs fall since resources are sitting idle,
and the economy starts to expand again. This
process of booms and busts is called the business
cycle.
To understand why these fluctuations might
occur, let's take this car analogy just a
little further and look at the engine. Much
like the four cylinder engine that powers
the Volkswagen of growth, an economy has four
components that make up GDP. Each represents
a different group that can purchase things
in the economy. They're consumer spending,
business spending which is called investment,
government spending, and net exports which
is basically spending by other countries.
If any one of these components loses power,
the economy will slow down, but not all of
them are created equal. Most economies rely
heavily on consumer spending. For example,
in the US, consumers account for about 70%
of GDP, but other countries might rely more
heavily on exports. The point is, changes in these four
components change the speed of the economy.
Thanks Thought Bubble. So when I'm driving
my car on the highway, I use cruise control
to regulate my speed. So why don't we have
cruise control for the economy? Well many
economists think that the government should
play a role in speeding up or slowing down
the economy. For example, when there's a recession,
the government can increase spending or cut
taxes so consumers have more money to spend.
Proponents of this policy argue that it would
get the economy back to full employment, but
it has its drawback: debt, which some economists
hate while others argue isn't very much of
a drawback at all. Stupid economic policy,
always resisting simplistic explanations.
We're gonna save the debate over how to fix
the economy for future videos, but for now
it's important for you to have a general understanding
of how the economy works and how it's measured.
After all, whether you're driving a Namco
in Greece, a Kia in Korea or a Ford in the
US, your livelihood and your future will be
shaped by what happens in the economy. So
wear your seat belt. By which I mean try to
save a little once in a while, OK?
So we've really just touched on these three
major indicators of economic health, and while
they can be useful in providing a broad overview
of a nation's economy, reality is, as usual,
a little more nuanced than that.
Mr. Clifford: Next week, we're gonna go under
the hood and look at the greasy, dirty details
of how economists calculate growth, and tune
up thee economy, and rev up their economic
engines and drive around the drag racing tr--
Adriene: OK, I think that's enough with the cars,
Thanks for watching, we'll see you next week.
Mr. Clifford: Thanks for watching Crash Course
Economics. It was made with the help of all
of these nice people. Now, if you want to
help keep Crash Course free for everyone forever,
please consider subscribing over at Patreon.
It's a voluntary subscription platform that
allows you to pay whatever you want per month
to make Crash Course exist, and it also increases
GDP. Thanks for watching, DFTBA.